welcome to this video playing a blitz
game on icc against hest our best horses
are best which i learned from the common
some check on the videos norwegian for
horses are best ok I normally play a 5
but Queenie 7 is a traditional line
which isn't isn't so bad as well it's
also geared towards the idea to play em
g65 later and before bed exchange them
the dark squared bishop ok so probably
he will go d5 now yeah now that's some
an interesting moment night b8 is of
course the normal looking news but I can
also play 98 I'm going to do that it
looks a bit strange but the idea is that
after f5 night f7 the night fulfills a
useful role in num covering the d6 pawn
like that of course why does quick here
with the opening of the C file but black
can basically argues that this isn't
such a big deal and mostly leads to an
exchange of of material I'm not sure
about that I don't know the line them in
big detail so I'm curious what's going
to happen
ok so here entered here immediately I
guess that rupee eight is right if he
takes that I have covered the seventh
rank and my idea could be to take and
play rook to e7 Ark of course after look
after king of it but he immediately
captured surprisingly this doesn't look
too threatening ok so Bishop d7 Roxy 7
is probably yeah it's not a big deal
or should I play b6 Bishop a 6 okay
whatever I'm doing I probably need to
need the King nearby Roxy seven I go
look B aid maybe look b3 was most
interesting choice now I'm intending to
play here a way to do i need to play
this why not be should be five can i
play Bishop b5 yeah why not a techie to
the thing is if the C file get some if I
just get the pieces exchanged here I'm
okay it's nothing nothing terrible
happening you phone came didn't you
didn't think about that move is f4 f4
his were just you know I'm play Bishop
e3 you don't want that and g6 is also
bad okay ah this is this is
uncomfortable really my dears to take at
that level seven
now it's probably still all right i mean
it looks uncomfortable but if i get rook
rook exchanges it's just nothing the
question is how to how to continue now
can I yeah we should easy fix you there
should be six is so a very annoying move
should I play Bishop d7 or not yeah
don't really see how how I can avoid it
there should be six something I cannot
allow so need to allow the exchange
maybe you can just check now yeah I
think it could have just given the check
and then Ruby g8
I'm not sure ERG fire could be could be
a nuisance so yeah I need to get get rid
of this rogue
so this end game he's got the space
space advantage it's not not great but
probably not the end of the world on the
queenside I I've got less space but
otherwise I'm fine should I play age
five yeah don't want kingi for check i
hope that i can simply yeah how to call
it with the fourth year
check yeah it's still it's still fairly
solid of course I'm I'm not especially
acted here and I want to try to do is
play b6 not be 75 to to to get the night
out p 6 yeah p 6 is playing a 6
Wow
time warning yeah this is great it's
almost almost suks 196 this is check
yeah wow I really miss played this
turtle named black four hits on time I
really shouldn't lose this end game I
can I cannot be so bad really i mean i'm
bruce of course this is obvious but I
shouldn't lose it I don't think so ok
it's actually the computer gives it as
completely winning
hmm yeah curious okay it's got the space
and the better night but isn't this
solid enough probably it isn't yeah but
if I don't play a try if it's also bad
habit this is better this is still
better now that white is clearly better
here I didn't want to do this because
after after this he'll win they have
five square and this is why I thought
okay let's go let's go h5 so that we
have an exchange here but check this is
simply am simply too bad nity I must
play be 6p I absolutely must play b6 the
compass very strong here I mean it
assistance always very strong but here
the computer gives a 5 which is much
much better and the point is that always
ever played the beep on you play a 6 and
this makes my night here completely dead
the same motif was in the game this is
where a five is better and after of
course is very hard to see in the Blitz
game yet here I must play b6 they
absolutely must play that so that I have
no not this so that I have this idea at
least and then fried 45 so activate my
my night somehow and then then I want to
get into zoosk wanna this could be a
draw I'm cautious now this could be at
least that gives me some chances to
fight I'm still worse but maybe i can i
can still draw and now I i was i was in
trouble
maybe maybe Bishop b5 wasn't wasn't so
great after all I don't think that this
can be so terrible if i get rid of the
rooks it's it's it's nothing really if I
just try to exchange he's going fon
Bishop a dream it's not not too
comfortable should I should I have
played something else and I don't know
yeah well I know why in my book I may I
have some other line I don't have
Queenie 7 in there f a five-term this
was really uncomfortable I couldn't
really couldn't really get out of it
yeah here Roxy a doll so strong yeah
yeah I thought that this would be would
be quite good he didn't go for that
though yeah it was very uncomfortable I
did he did a good job at playing this
year hmm okay thanks for watching